[Music]
congrats to you too
buddy congrat don't bury the ladies
i haven't seen you since i think i'm a
married woman
but girl you are totally burying the
lead here you know what i'm talking
about to do that
you make it look hiding
[Music]
you are making it look so stylish well
you have to right see that i mean so
it's a long nine to ten months girl you
know you you have to enjoy it what are
you enjoying most about this journey uh
donuts so far
but besides the obvious you know
i'm looking forward to it you know this
is it's all an exciting journey so far
i'm just taking it as it comes every
week
it's something new and i'm just taking
it i'm enjoying it
rocking a custom-made sequin halter and
matching pants re-reposed with her man
asap rocky her motto maternity but make
it fashion fashion is one of my favorite
things so
you know redefining what it means to
even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend
what are you looking forward to as you
move into a new chapter of your life i'm
just excited for what i don't know yet
you know everything is new to me so
you know a source tells e.t they will be
very hands-on parents and that la will
be home base for the couple after the
baby is born this weekend riri was busy
promoting her fenty beauty and skin
lines and then hit up the super bowl
taking care of a girl absolutely holding
that umbrella for you remember that
corny joke of mine
you gotta start with that that's an
ongoing joke you gotta retire that one
what's your beauty regimen looking like
these days
um
staying moisturized from head to toe you
know butter drop is my go-to is there
one product that you feel like you
cannot leave home without uh
gloss bomb
glass bomb for sure is that the mvp
you're wearing yes it is oh look at you
bala babe i just went to ask
and do i smell like you ready yay well
if you smell like me it's probably
because you're wearing it
right do you think this stage in your
life is going to inspire new music
oh gosh
you can't ever you know this one my fans
love you you know because you asked all
the good questions
uh well
yes you're still gonna get music from me
maybe a lullaby i can see you and asap
dropping demos in the studio
oh my goodness not a lullaby my fans
would kill me they waited this long for
a lullaby edness to sleep with this
music they're like we are grown when are
we gonna get fenty baby
well
one thing at a time valentine's day is
coming up so what is the most savage
woman around have planned for her man
and what is she expecting
from her options you know just pulling
them out my uh my little closet
[Music]
you